en perú y hay que esperar con con
serenidad sobre unas elecciones que
pueden resultar bastante polémicas los
retos para quien sea que arde las
elecciones son fuertes son grandes y
muchas veces hasta podríamos decir
impensables hay mucho que hacer mucho
que revertir mucho que mejorar por el
bien de la población peruana y en méxico
creo yo que esta elección puede
representar una pérdida del poder de
andrés manuel lópez obrador y de morena
sobre todo en las elecciones locales que
son la base para las próximas
presidenciales así tendrán la oposición
que dar de una manera estratégica más
fuerte en caso que hubiese una victoria
relativa en estas elecciones y amorena
tratar de rectificar o mejorar aquello
en lo que falló que a estas alturas
resulta bastante complicado en la
personalidad del presidente mexicano